after yesterday it's becoming apparent
to a lot of people that President Trump
is in major legal trouble yeah no this
is a true story
Wow you're a very sympathetic crowd and
terrible actors now it's getting crazy
people in the White House say that
president's been affected by this it is
being reported today by White House
insiders at present Trump feels like
this is the quote that the walls are
closing in yeah yeah
yeah when they heard this Mexico stepped
up and offered to help pay for those
walls
Omarosa is weighing in on the
president's troubles because we need to
know what Omarosa are yeah in an
interview yesterday Omarosa said that
the Michael Cohen plea deal is the
beginning of the end for President Trump
beginning of the end
in response Trump said it is not it's
the middle of the end what do you see
the end is there the end is fantastic
you're gonna love it huh oh it's crazy
he had a big rally in West Virginia and
during the rally President Trump
rarely rarely spoke about the legal
cases barely even mentioned them instead
all he talked about was his space force
yeah yeah yeah whose space for us ya
know it started to become pretty clear
why Trump is so interested in a quick
exit from the earth
so this story has sort of like just you
know it's taking up all the news and
taking up all the oxygen there's other
stories going on out there I don't know
if you know this but a Russian nuclear
missile has been lost at sea yeah yeah
the story was reported in the kids
magazine sleep well children why aren't
we talking about that there's a Russian
nuclear missile rolling around the
bottom of the ocean I thought you meant
that there was a magazine called sleep
well children oh I'll be all over that
yeah I mean that in the most innocent
way you bastard damn now it's off me and
it's on him that's the important thing
in an interview Kylie Jenner says that
during her pregnancy she wanted to quote
just enjoy her privacy yeah yes she said
this on the latest episode of keeping up
with Kylie Jenner's fetus so that
follows her fetus archeologists are
claiming they found a lost city in rural
Kansas believe that then today they
admitted they got really high last night
and watched The Wizard of Oz
insane
you